johan est il apte à briguer un second
mandat la question fait débat aux états
unis c'est ce que va nous montrer notre
correspondant à washington thomas venez
regarder
la question peut sembler prématuré elle
est pourtant bien d'actualité notamment
dans les rangs démocrates selon le
washington post joe biden aurait fait
part à ses soutiens de son intention de
briguer un deuxième mandat en 2024 une
façon peut être de répondre à des
rumeurs qui se faisaient de plus en plus
persistantes sur une éventuelle volonté
de la part du président de ne pas se
représenter de tout miser sur un mandat
unique alors cette éventualité d'une
candidature de joe biden en 2024 divise
il ya ceux qui rappellent les précédents
clinton et obama qui malgré des
résultats décevant lors des élections de
mi mandat était parvenu à se faire
réélire il ya ceux aussi qui ne veulent
pas du tout entendre parler d'une
nouvelle primaire d'une nouvelle
désignation d'un candidat pour le camp
démocrate pour la campagne de 2024 et
puis de l'autre côté il ya ceux qui
émettent quelques doutes sur l'âge et
l'état de santé de joe biden lui qui je
vous le rappelle a subi vendredi une
coloscopie lors d'un examen médical de
routine examens en cours duquel les
médecins ont affirmé que le président
américain était en pleine forme reste
qu'il y a encore des doutes sur sa
capacité à amener une campagne
présidentielle en 2024 qui serait à très
différente de celle de 2020 ou les
déplacements et les meetings avaient été
réduits au strict minimum en raison du
coc vide mais finalement le problème
numéro un pour joe biden s'est peut-être
sa cote de popularité qui est en chute
libre depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines elle s'établit à 41 % et selon
un récent sondage
64% des américains ne sont pas
favorables au fait que joe biden brigue
un second mandat
et finalement la situation est assez
similaire de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique au sein du parti républicain
où il ya aussi des divisions sur
l'éventualité d'une candidature de
donald trump on sait que ce dernier
entretient le flou sur son avenir
politique il devrait sans doute se
prononcer après les élections de mi
mandat mais il n'est pas à exclure
aujourd'hui que le duel pour la
présidence en 2024 soit finalement le
même que celui de 2020